[Music]
in the days before uber and lyft sorry
lifties it was sometimes very hard to
get if you were in the city crowded
night in new york it was hard to get a
cab those memories are fading now but it
was not too long ago and one night
christian and i were out and we couldn't
hey look it was probably a holiday or
something we just couldn't get a cab we
were kind of far away from the apartment
we needed to get to and i heard somebody
call my name hey i don't even know if
they said my name was just like hey and
i looked over his cops two cops in a car
like beat cops
and um i thought i'd done something
wrong so of course i got nervous but i
approached the car and they they said
are you uh
yeah i forget what they noticed me from
they knew you and they knew and they
liked you yes are you afraid to say that
a little bit they did like me they were
fans yes so we i mean we i can't say
that word we started talking to them and
they were so nice and they offered us a
ride to where we were going yeah it was
and we got in the cop car and they drove
us all the way across town to where we
were going and we probably interrupted
their stakeout
um
i know they were like sitting in a car
that's true i'm wondering what criminal
got away but they uh and tax but people
are gonna love to hear this like
taxpayer money is gonna like help us get
a ride home but uh this was back in the
day when you could say could i get a
lift and it meant something else it
didn't mean you got in your phone like
with an i yeah they gave us the lift
home so uh if those two cops are
listening a hearty thank you from us
both yes
life could be a dream
life could be a
dream you're listening to life is short
i am you're no longer in need of a ride
host life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
justin long that's my name oh yeah yeah
uh and with me as always is
no this this might be the worst intro no
so far so good christian long his
brother yeah
yes well done
and um
god that was
how long ago would you say that was my
memory is so bad i would say it was over
10 years ago you had to remind me of
that story i forgot about riding in that
car only because you've had so many
interactions with cops over the years
yeah i've gotten so many rides from
coffee they all blend together but uh
that was a that was a an experience they
were very i i just always think of cops
as being like authoritative and scary it
was cool i felt like one of the boys yes
you know we became like boys with them
yeah because they were two well they
were men but actually we're now of an
age where we probably would refer to
them as boys sure but you might say that
night we rode in a car with boys yes
speaking of stretches
uh funny enough i'm glad you mentioned
riding cars with the
boys oh boy
because our guest today
was one of the stars of that movie
from 20 years ago he's amazing in that
movie he's amazing in everything he's
one of my favorite actors uh and he's
he's an old friend we got to work
together years ago
and so i'm so excited for you to hear
our ketchup i was excited to do it our
guest is steve zahn one of the best
truly one of the best yeah when i was
watching i feel like we do say that a
lot and you say one of my favorite apps
but he this guy i know i mean he truly
one of your favorite actors one of
everyone's favorite actors when i was a
young man when i was a teenager like
fantasizing about being an actor he was
one of the guys i really looked up to
and um
i discovered him in a movie called well
i think i saw suburbia i saw a bunch of
his reality bites in reality bites of
course um in the 90s he did a lot of
like great indie movies and um but the
one that i always loved was safe men
with sam rockwell it's if you haven't
seen it it's just so great that's such a
joke that's a good recommendation
because that's like a completely under
the radar movie i know it is it's great
so john hamburg wrote directed it he
went on to write meet the parents it's
just um mark ruffalo is in it and peter
dinklage yeah a very young cast yeah
it's great but um
so check that out if you haven't and uh
i was i i don't know what to say about
this guy he's just you worked with them
in strange wilderness the cult classic
is it fair to call this club classic at
this point i think so so
i think it's like a stoner called
classic yes and it's one of those movies
that
comes up more i think people have like
kind of discovered it uh over the years
it's it's gotten uh legs it had it got
abysmal reviews yes but it's like really
funny i think so i think it's one of the
funny i i remember getting really stoned
and laughing so hard um i saw it a
couple times in the theaters i don't
know what that says about my taste but
well critics
abort it
they did abhor it yeah i think it got a
zero in fact on rotten tomatoes yeah um
but it is it's one of those like it's so
that mr deeds did we've talked about
this to make ourselves feel better for
ladies manor which is also uh
the potential to be a cult uh classic
maybe not classic but a cult hit because
i think what you need is for to perform
poorly at the box office
people say that about tusk it didn't do
well at the box office and then people
discover it and whatever i don't know um
but it is funny i think and um and i
always like the people that approach me
about that movie i always get i always
think like oh i we we could be friends
you know it's got like a very specific
sense of humor because it's really
stupid but like really like funny stupid
yes
or is it stupid funny uh we're both both
made me [ __ ] funny stupid funny
that's i don't know uh the guy who wrote
it fred wolfe and the two guys peter
gaulke they were um wolf wolf now woof
fred wolfe yeah there's a hard time with
that you said woof fred wolfe there we
go wolf i always forget the l since you
were a little kid that's been the
hardest word for you wolves wolf
werewolf werewolves
well he was anyway fred was one of the
writers uh on snl when they were doing
during like the class during my favorite
era of snow like the um he wrote a lot
of those great uh
chris farley adam sandler sketches and
he wrote the one he wrote canteen boy
which is one of my favorites uh
that's a great one yeah he's really fun
so um anyway steve son has done more
than strange wilderness we should just
yeah oh my god because he's he's been in
so many classic movies yeah um he was
the guy who for so long was like sam
rockwell was for for a long time they
would get people would know their faces
but would never wouldn't necessarily
know their names and just because he's
such a
i think this word gets overused and
acting but he's such a chameleon he
really is though he really transforms
and um
and i've always been one of my favorite
character actors and now a lot of people
are seeing him in god i love this show
so much this hbo show called white lotus
have you seen it you saw one episode i
saw the first episode the other night
man really good it is
i've been obsessed with it i watched it
i binged it um and i can't wait to watch
it again it's so good so if you've been
watching that uh
a lot of good recommendations in this
instance yes
man and white lotus and he's so good in
running cars with boys if you haven't
seen that um
anyway
yeah he's a great actor and um a good
friend and it was great to catch up with
him so uh let's hear it please my
ketchup with my old pal and one of my
favorite actors steve zahn
life could be a dream
hello hello again you're blooming over
we'll meet again
[Music]
you look great you got a cool cap on
uh you you you guys this is my hair oh
that's so long yeah is it long cut is it
long for something
you know i just kept it growing just
because
and then
and then i kept my beard growing that
was crazy oh yeah you i just kept saying
like
cut it
and i said what if
tomorrow
i get called and they asked
you know yeah grizzly i want you to play
a pirate i'm a character actor so i got
to keep it going steve is spitting into
a cup
um
does the tobacco how often do should i
not talk about it
you know
it depends
are you is it when you're stressed
no no it's just it's just all the time i
don't have people buried on my property
i just chew all right yeah yeah that's
that's
worse vices you could have people buried
on your property because i know you have
a lot of problems
but that wouldn't be because of me
yeah and you wouldn't admit it on a show
probably unless you were just done
hiding
that would be a scoop exactly that'd be
a great scoop um uh speaking of bodies
being buried you were all over your
notes yeah i have no idea
christian wrote it my brother wrote him
was he out with us that night i was
trying to remember because you met him
oh yeah i think so i think he might have
been our friend togo was out can we
steve and i
i don't know if this would be fun for
people to hear about but um
we had a night out yeah oh my god i
don't know where that ranks in your
nights out but it it's up there for me
it was it was that was pretty intense
yeah with kevin with kevin at the door
that's yeah so kevin ring the doorbell
and propping him up between the door and
the screen door
so
kevin heffernan he might not want us to
say this but i'm sure he seems like a
pretty like he doesn't care he doesn't
care he was we all got drunk we had a
fun time out with uh who togo and jonah
and we were in santa monica and we just
had we tied one on
and kevin um
at a certain point of the night i
remember you know when you look at your
friend and you think um and you see them
you see that they've taken the turn
but but you don't want to be alarmed on
their behalf you know you don't want
wait
yeah because they're they're working so
hard at pretending
to show you that they're they're not
drunk to maintain normalcy yeah
which is weird it's like just
own it dude yeah
good yeah he got kind of quiet and he
looked
he looked like he was doing the math in
his head like when am i gonna puke like
where like where can i do it and i saw
him
trying to make those calculations and
get kind of contemplative and um i think
that's when we i think we might have
already been in the car at that point he
was just yeah he was quiet for a while i
remember just thinking like oh and kevin
had been so [ __ ] loud and boisterous
and then he just got
quiet and then
we
all we were all in we responsibly
driving we had hired uh
um
and um we we got him two i think we were
almost at his house yeah very close yeah
and he
just unloaded it was like it looked like
fake window
it just turned his head
but it was like it was almost like
someone talking like we're talking yeah
and then
it was just like all right
it was hysterical and i've been there
before so i'm not judging but like it
was just
you know it was the mechanics of like
pressing down on a window opener wasn't
it was locked how well
yeah it really was just like
yeah it was all over the window because
he hadn't rolled it down and it was yeah
it was toward the outside
it was in that direction
you could see the outside
so
so i don't think any of the puke made it
outside but i remember it looking like
um
also you don't want to lie that's
another like
friendship like challenge like you don't
want to laugh he was a friend we were we
don't you don't want to make him feel
bad in that moment but it was hilarious
it was immediately funny it was very
funny
and it was it looked like i remember
like fake vomit like uh like a prop guy
would yeah be like well that's a little
too on the nose and i can't remember
after like we must have tipped that dude
like we tipped him a lot we did a lot
and and i remember you we propped up
kevin at his door
like you said he was ringing the d he
was ringing yeah his wife was like yeah
fun
to one night yeah yeah that's right he
was like well i mean because he had
little kids he did he did and it was
like one of those days and you know at
like 6 00 am they were they were all on
him yeah go wake up your dad yeah
because he also looks like hop on pop
you know he looks like the pop and hop
on pop but they just jumping on his
belly
uh
you know what that's like what what is
that like when you have a night like
that and you gotta you got the kid the
kids don't know it you can't let them
know it no i tell you what it sobers you
up big time yeah that and horses what
how do how do horses do that well horses
don't care oh guys don't yeah horses
don't celebrate christmas right you know
what i mean like yeah
horses are uh atheists
yeah they're like where's this where is
it
yeah
so you gotta feed them how many horses
do you have
just two now oh wow and so you still
gotta do it yeah yeah that's right and i
got coats too i gotta feed those and
then you go you know
clean the waterers and do the whole
thing so it's a daily ritual which i
really enjoy what do you do when um
you're not around well what do you do
because you travel so much so what do
you do with the horses and the goats and
all that
did you try to your kids i bet your kids
must take care of them yeah they do but
they're older now but um yeah i mean
it's not you know i just let them out in
the field i mean you know horses have
been living in the woods for millions of
years
i
yeah they can their stuff they're
sufficient i rode my first horse uh in
iceland i was just in iceland
oh that's supposed to be great oh man
steve it was [ __ ]
you gotta go i i it's unlike anything
i've ever i've never seen anything like
this like everywhere you turn it's it's
like a new uh
overwhelming spectacle of nature and the
people are amazing oh so
like let's have fun they're just such
warm
lovely people and to the point where
when i got back here
everything like
the ugliness of people yelling and
beeping their horns you know it was like
it all it was amplified it was all like
really uh i j it's amazing how quickly
you get used to like a more docile
gentle yeah man i mean it's it's kind of
once you take that out of your existence
well you probably felt that when you
moved to kentucky i imagine you live a
very i always really admire we have
always lived we've always lived outside
even like when we first met
we moved we moved to a cabin from new
york in pennsylvania oh wow and we and
we commuted in huh doing theater eight
nine eight shows a week
what yeah dude we bought this cabin
because we were on this national tour of
a of a musical for like 13 months and
saved all this money which we're like oh
um bye-bye birdie with me
oh my god
yes wait okay
i don't know if you can tell the story
that's my favorite story the tommy tune
story what the i've tried
i've i've tried to tell it i've tried it
it's hard to tell it is especially audio
right right it's true i can yeah
that would be hard to tell well we can
cut it out yeah
yes we can cut it out but if you we can
you paint the picture you're you're of
course we just missed each other yeah
like yeah i was hugo peabody okay and
tommy and tommy was you know he's tall
he's huge he's like six six or something
yeah yeah he's he's not as tall as he is
his legs
are really tall yeah and he just didn't
get me but his boyfriend
or
yeah i think he's his boyfriend um he
got he laughed at me but my wife my
girlfriend at the time he thought she
was really funny so we hung out all the
time oh oh
well we go to dinners and stuff but i
was a jester for him for his
whatever for his boyfriend and offstage
he would try very hard to understand my
humor yeah
and so i would like joke with him as he
came off stage and i was going on
and it was just never the reaction was
never
was never laughing it was always just
like a tilt of the head
and the squinty eyes and then he would
put his fingers out and like he was
crushing my head he'd go
and then and that was his kind of
acknowledgement of like my humor like
don't get you
well that's
that's what i loved about it was like he
was shutting you off
he was just like okay
go on stage and act
but i also like i like the backstory i
forgot this part of the backstory that
like the boyfriend did get you and was
like it would like joke around and so he
was probably there was probably like a
mix of like i want to understand him i
want to understand what my boyfriend
sees in his humor but i acknowledge that
you are funny too but some people
i'm i'm
know i'm not just gonna stand here yeah
yeah i have to do something chris and i
were talking about this you're great
in everything like you're one of those
actors that i've told you this before
you know how much uh
you know how i feel about you but like i
i imagine a lot of people think that of
you so even if it's like
even if it's like oh you were whatever
they're recognizing you from i imagine
they like you and it's you it's probably
usually very positive it's kind of the
equivalent if you go like what do you do
yeah i'm a teacher
oh what grade
yeah sixth grade
do you
do you know phillip do you know phillip
yeah
johnson
no no
no name some students
sarah mcgillicuddy
no
no
no maybe you're not a teacher yeah yeah
the disappointment the fading well i got
the craziest one i think i've said i
might have told you this where she this
girl goes i know you're an actor it's
killing me what were you in
and i was like oh i don't know a bunch
of things it's embarrassing she goes
come on just name a couple i know
whatever i it's i i need to know and i
go okay this is before like phones with
the internet stuff and i was like i
don't know this that she goes no no and
i'm like naming up for the couple things
i've done and she goes no and finally
she goes okay dude i get it you're in
movies jeez
and i was like wait what
you can't do that
turn it around on you yeah that's that
that those aren't the rules um
i just start with the most obscure [ __ ]
uh-huh yeah do you know me from this
freak freak talks about sex oh yeah
that's i think i know uh josh hamilton
is that josh hamilton yeah that's like
you know what my son and i watched that
like a good movie months ago yeah he was
like yeah let's see this is a good movie
he loved it yeah i think it's called
blowing smoke now or something josh josh
is [ __ ] great uh he is so great in
that yeah i called him right after i was
like dude yeah
phenomenal
yeah yeah what do your kids think of i
mean he liked that one but are there
other ones that you are there ones that
you're proud of and they're like
does that ever happen yeah a bunch
yeah yeah i mean they're like brilliant
they're like you know how old are they
now steve uh henry's 21 and my
daughter's audrey is 19. oh my god
wild
it's crazy and they're they're they're
amazing i mean they're so smart is he
still playing lacrosse he was and then
he quit and
he was gonna go to school to play and
then and then he was like i want to be a
playwright
man whoa
and then he went to he got into the
theater school at depaul oh amazing and
then he and then he quit he he dropped
out okay which is great yeah
he's an amazing writer and he and so now
he's gonna he's kind of created a major
at university of kentucky and creative
writing oh how cool oh that's good to
hear and then my daughter's at um
baldwin wallace
um yeah
musical theater uh yeah conservatory oh
my gosh she's
she's kind of got
our genes and yeah that makes sense
was that how did you feel about that
because i i know
you know we talk about like
people who who have kids who i've heard
a lot of actor parents want to shield
their kids from that but is it it sounds
like they're good kids i imagine they
grew up on a farm they grew up with you
guys as parents yeah so they they had
access to all kinds of different stuff
yeah which is odd that they that they
kind of
ultimately came back to this kind of
what might be like nature versus nurture
i mean you guys have you guys are such
performers i mean you're you're a
performer in the in the best way not in
like a
it's not that you perform in life but um
it's something that you're is in your
blood so i guess it makes sense did your
parents have that i mean like do they
look at you in the choice you made like
the path you took and and was that was
that did that seem natural to them um or
was that a surprise yeah and they had no
clue what
you know i grew up very suburban kind of
kid when i told them i was dropping out
of school to become an actor honestly my
mom was like oh that's exciting
oh really
yeah it was
like it wasn't a hesitation it was
really amazing yeah because i think they
they understood they were like yeah we
kind of thought that would happen that
you would drop out yeah
which is i mean yeah which
that's but how nice to to be like
immediately accept like a decision
never one minute
wow
in my life
oh i've never heard that reaction
i've never heard that reaction even your
dad your dad was i learned from my notes
was a lutheran minister
yeah yeah he was he was he loved it oh
and even like the potential very
artistic guy i mean the guy's an artist
for real a performer an artist you know
a writer well sure as a minister he'd
have to perform and
but was there because of his was there
ever a hesitation because like he
thought he imagined like a hedonistic
like hollywood lifestyle no
no my dad was extremely yeah he's a
chaplain on universities i grew up oh oh
you know so you know
you gotta be pretty cool and wow that's
so cool uh
and is your mom still they're still in
minnesota yeah
um
so were you able to see them much during
the pandemic yeah we drove up a couple
times and went to a cabin and stuff oh
cool but uh but now my mom just was down
here a couple weeks ago so it was good
so we're getting back into swing oh
that's great that's tough when your
folks are old and you know it's like i
know not going home for christmas and
stuff it's it takes a toll like you
realize how precious i mean every year
becomes
especially the older you get that's what
i've kind of why we call the show life
is short i started to get really i
started to become very aware of time the
passing of time and and it carried
it had a lot more weight um and so yeah
yeah i know a single christmas is like
we don't have that many
right christmases you know i think
that's actually in your movie it's in
it's great pivot to 8-bit christmas
there's a moment where david cross
says um
says something like that you know we
don't get a lot of these oh it's so
great to see him again geez
he's so brilliant man i know did you
guys shoot that during the pandemic yeah
it was really miserable
it was
well i'm just saying like it was like it
was in toronto
in the winner
they were in complete lockdown oh my god
right of course i go up i go up there
and i land at toronto international
terminal dude i was the only person in
the immigration oh my god i walked in
there and i looked around going what
what do we do
yeah some guy was like pointing
and i go oh [ __ ] i gotta go you know
and there was one did you did you go
through the whole maze of uh the ropes
yeah at that point yeah did you i found
myself doing that when it's empty i i
know i like like a mouse like a trained
rodent instead of just going under so i
go through the whole thing and then i go
to the hotel and i have to quarantine
for 14 days right
and they give me a key and i go to my
room and they're like it works once
what that's
that's where it sinks in because you're
trapped and i'm like click clack and i
open the door and i was like click click
oh
oh
my god and they were like just remember
it works once just remember it works
once
oh okay so i went in my room i shut the
door and it was like daunting right i'm
like oh and trust me you know it was
just sweet it was nice the whole thing
had a little treadmill which oh
and
like to make you really feel like a ham
like a rat like a i gained like 10
pounds in like 14 days so what so
there's not a part of you that's like oh
you know what like i'm gonna break
because i know you're outdoors all the
time you're i know you're naturally like
wired to be outside and to be active but
was there a part of you that like
was able to embrace it i'm just going to
like watch movies and be fun oh yeah no
it was great it was it was pure bliss
for like eight days you know the fun
thing about making a movie is hanging
out with everybody
shooting
totally in toronto is a great place to
do that there's one of my favorite bars
so that's what i meant i couldn't wait
to work i was like please just let me
work all day but even on set you know
it's like you're segregated
i know yes so it wasn't i know it wasn't
like a blast
yeah yeah well there's also something
psychological not because of the movie
just because of the situation no no of
course i i had this similar thing happen
where
and when you can't see people's faces
you know there's something about um
i don't know what it is i mean but it's
it's things that like i think the more
we get locked into phones and stuff and
and you know these these devices like
the less we'll really care about it but
we happen to have
been raised in a generation without that
stuff so
there's something about not seeing
somebody's face their face being covered
up i agree it's really interesting yeah
yeah it's harder to do anything
you lose
everything yeah yeah it's a great time
for people with really pretty eyes and a
shitty face
they're like oh please let this keep
going like you can take your mask off
i don't know 99
um are are have that vaccine
i know i'm just
yeah i'm just i'm just so worried about
it and i see i if i had if that were the
case with me and people might think it
is um i would i'd be scared then for the
uh the reveal because eventually you
have to reveal but hopefully that's out
yeah [ __ ]
you were two times speech champion
minnesota state speech champion
i didn't know this is two years in a row
what does that mean
in different categories
sorry you were mumbling what did you say
in different categories what one was in
serious prose and then the next year i
took the drama
oh
snap
what is what do you remember what you
read i mean do you read shakespeare what
do you what do you read for the first
year for prose i read portrait of a girl
in glass which was a short story
basically of of the glass menagerie ah
oh of uh written by tennessee williams
and and then the next year
i read paul's speech
from chorus line
and it was just that just was you know
this
became public basically oh wow
and so that was um kind of a big deal
was that in lieu of like an acting
program or did they have a drama program
or is it a separate thing in my high
school yeah yeah
it was called the clam i mean
declaration and it was really big in
minnesota it was like
and you you know held a book and
you know elected
competitions and
and it was about i don't know you're
judged on whatever but um well like
performance even drama you had it in
your hands and you'd walk down hallways
and there would be
lined with kids like
like with their books open talking
oh my to
front of them oh my god and talking and
doing their thing practicing [ __ ] off
surreal
did you did other kids at the school was
that considered like a cool thing to do
or like socially what was that no i sort
of there's a leading question
so how cool dude it was so yeah i know
it wasn't cool but it wasn't dumb i mean
it wasn't like you know that was
something i always struggled with and
i'm sure a lot of people do and it's a
theme of a big christmas is like caring
about what other people think you know
you
you you were probably okay with the
weirdness of it or or or is that
incorrect i felt like an outsider in
high school huh like
those guys yeah yeah i mean like
but i was friend you know i played
football oh you did it right i was kind
of friends with everybody you know yeah
how so did the what did the football
kids think of and vice versa like what
did those two groups think of one
another i got like two captains of my
football team in the in the musical oh
her senior year really like you got to
do it and they and they loved it they
were like this is the greatest
experience i've ever you know yeah yeah
closing night like crying and hugging
like giving each other roses yeah
yeah yeah no
tons of makeup just tons of cake makeup
with like crows crow's feet in your eyes
because i'm playing an older gentleman
morning mayor shin yeah i played a lot
of old guys characters he had like lines
yes yes yes and now we got the lines
isn't that great isn't that crazy it's
built in i did like old i remember doing
old but i remember doing the secret
garden and i played the gardener ben and
and i like i couldn't sing i couldn't i
had no rhythm so i i just spoke the song
it's amazed this garden it's a maze of
ways you know just like kind of like
is it like a stereotypical old guy yeah
i played it i played an old guy it was a
greek chorus
and lisa strada oh my god
and and audition was no this was first
year in college
and the audition was to come out as an
115 year old individual
and sing a song
so i i put i put water in my mouth it
took me like a minute to get down stage
and then the music started and i opened
my mouth slightly that's amazing all of
it just drooled out
it was all out of my mouth and then i
just fell back
[ __ ] great i love that that's right
up my alley that's great
where where were you
but your plan was originally to become
my notes told me this to become a marine
yeah when i was in high school i was
like yeah i just want to do that and i
was like fascinated with military
history yeah yeah
what sparked that wha why do you do you
know what i don't know huh i don't know
maybe movies yeah i remember as a little
kid going to gettysburg yeah i loved it
i could go stand in a field and i was my
imagination would like we got to go to
more places like this oh wow and then i
was like we live in minnesota there's
nothing here they didn't fight there
yeah it was so [ __ ] peaceful there
yeah i remember being in like the field
where they did pickett's charge they did
they did they performed picket star and
um all right guys
i know it's hot and you're wearing wool
and i'm sorry about that so what what
derailed that how did you then i mean it
it seems to me such a natural transition
to go from really then i just realized
oh i don't want to be a marine i want to
pretend to be a marine i don't want to
go through all the crap i don't wear the
outfit and like do the stuff
but i had those guys at my house oh wow
my mom was like do you gotta tell those
guys you know i was like i know oh man
which is a man what's going on you know
the recruiters who come to my football
games oh wow really because you probably
were like
courting it a little bit yeah i was i'd
go in and talk to them and like her mom
it's no wonder she was so because i mean
like for a parent they must have been so
concerned i mean such as obviously yeah
oh she must have been no one but i'm put
but she understood
my enthusiasm yeah she understood it
yeah but never said like you shouldn't
do that that's that's stupid
yeah oh no she knew that eventually i
would come to my senses i think
[Music]
tis the season to cozy up next to a fire
with a cold case and your favorite crime
solvent partner if you don't have a
crime solving partner maybe this is the
year you you find one and you can
connect over your love of murder
mysteries and cold case shows our
sponsor hunt a killer is a murder
mystery subscription box where you play
as a detective who's solving a case and
i'm telling you i it feels like you were
an actual detective in a real life
investigation now i've never been an
actual detective in an investigation but
it's the closest i've ever felt actually
being one so this might be for you and
i'm talking specifically to margaret
reid christian's fiance and i can tell
you maggie margaret she's been having so
much fun playing hunter killer in all of
their games you can sift through
documents evidence audio recordings and
case files until you solve the murder
every item you receive is so realistic
it makes you feel like you're actually
working on a murder investigation it's
played right at home alone or with
friends or family the most important
part is that part of the proceeds go to
the cold case foundation which actually
helps solve and support the victims of
real cases right now you can go to hunt
a killer dot com slash justin and use
code justin for 10 off your purchase
again make sure to use code justin
hunt a killer dot com slash justin for a
ten dollar discount i've been traveling
a lot lately and uh
i packed all the essentials except for
one that i really regretted forgetting i
didn't pack my plus cbd how could you
forget that i i don't know but you don't
have to shame me on top of it i already
had adjustable sleeping i'm incredulous
i was too at myself i was so mad plus
cbd is um they're sleep gummies if this
is the first time you're hearing the
show they are especially formulated by a
team of medical experts and doctors
they're gummies that taste great but
they also are made with award-winning
cbd
combined with melatonin magnolia bark
and lemon balm
all
natural good stuff i think it's worth
mentioning that all plus cbd products
are third party tested and fully
traceable from seed to shelf so you can
be assured you're getting the highest
quality hemp cbd
like we said they help with sleep but
they also reduce stress they alleviate
soreness just overall improve your
quality of life the plus cbd is san
diego's trusted cbd brand and the number
one selling natural hemp extract in the
united states so if you want to sleep
better tonight just visit plus cbd oil
dot com and enter promo code long for 40
off your order that's code long
at plus cbd oil dot com for 40 off
hello
[Music]
uh your first professional i didn't know
this your first professional play was
uh bloxy blue so funny i was just
thinking about bloxy blues because when
you mentioned the football players i
remember playing
epstein arnold epstein and biloxi blues
and in high school and the
two that was such a great part and the
tumi part was uh
the the acting teacher there recruited
one of the football guy with this guy
tim he was a offensive lineman big guy
to play
uh toomey to play yeah yeah the
christopher walker
what um
who did you play
i played donald j carney oh go yeah yeah
great he sings he sings on this stoop
yes it was such an amazing i was working
at a machine shop literally making
parts for cassette players and grenades
and and and grenades
yeah oh that's it was horrible job oh my
god just tool and i just all day making
parts and then i auditioned for this
play
and and they were and
my my mentor frank pollute was like dude
you got to go audition i said it's
professional show and i'm not
professional there's the canadian coming
out
and i was like that breaks the rules yes
i'm sorry i came out a rule breaker and
he said go and i say all right so i went
and then i was waiting to hear uh-huh
and all i thought about was this play
and i called the theater from my work at
lunch and i was like hey
i was just wondering did you guys cast
that play and they were like who is this
i said steve's on and i came in and they
were like oh we were just going to call
you we'd like to offer you the part
and my life changed and i went and i
quit my job oh and god
and i was just like at my machine all
smiles like i was so excited and then i
met all these great actors from new york
yeah and they were all advising me to go
train and it was such a eight month run
and so wow
you know doing a long run or something
and dude it was so much fun you were
doing you were acting in school right in
college yeah i was it well i dropped out
out of college i i mean i guess what i'm
saying is like you had already had
success in some as an actor and like in
some form yeah but not as a professional
right right right i was getting paid
right that's the how much right they
were like 350
i was like
are you kidding me yeah yeah
yeah that changes everything well so it
was crazy what whose advice did you then
take i mean
there's also the thing where it's like
yeah the world opens up but then it
becomes kind of daunting all the
different venues you can take so
who where did you settle what what did
you decide to do you went right to new
york they were like no go train you're
good you got to go train i was like oh
okay what do we what do you mean
audition for these schools i was like
okay juilliard a-c-t-a-r-t
and i just i didn't know i just did it
and i drove to chicago
i auditioned for these schools and i got
into the american repertory theater
at harvard the two two-year program all
my classmates were graduate age oh wow
so i got in because of my professional
experience wow i was younger than
everybody and it was great and i met
everybody and i got to work with amazing
directors and
you know cherry jones and you know andre
serbon and you know people are really
so important work with people like that
at that point totally
and you you know where you're just
sucking everything up and you're working
with brilliant people that are advising
you like don't do this do this you know
it's the best education i mean it's it's
just to be around them every night and
yeah and i didn't pretend to know
anything that's really important with
young people it's like don't pretend to
know stuff
be vulnerable be be open be be naive
yeah yeah what what was the thing you
think you did have that so many people
don't what was the thing that you felt
you were able because i i have a guess i
i have a theory about like
you to me are so
present you you never you are there's
nothing false about you when you're when
you're working i mean
when you're not working you're totally
phony and full of [ __ ] but like but
you're you're
you just seem so committed like
everything you do i i i i've never seen
you not committed so how does that
happen yeah it's interesting i mean i
always felt
like that i was good at it yeah
but it wasn't until i was around other
people like when i went to art where
people would would tell you why you were
good yeah and then you started you
started
kind of acknowledging those things and
understanding it as opposed to it being
this magical thing like um
right i guess i am kind of
method in a way
yeah you know i guess i am kind of you
start labeling it
i remember a teacher saying i was doing
a scene and he said you see how steve
is looking out the window when he's
doing his the scene mm-hmm he was like
there's no window there but i really
he's looking out the window uh-huh i
think you know what i mean yeah yeah and
i remember him
and i thought oh that's interesting yeah
it's just it's a tough thing to talk
about because there's also part of that
is just like pure natural instinct
there's an aversion to
dishonesty maybe like there's an
aversion maybe
you start i don't know yeah you know
when it's not
right yeah and yeah no this isn't yes it
god damn it stop yeah you feel it yes
yeah there are moments of yours that i
marvel at that are um that are so hard
to replicate because they're so
immediate or i'm thinking of one in
particular in safemen where i think i've
talked to you about this where to this
day it's i i think about it a lot
whenever i have to be like surprised
when i if something has to take me by
surprise it's it's the moment you're
stealing the stanley cup
and and you i i'm sure i've told you
about this and uh that you get caught
you get caught you and sam rockwell get
busted stealing and you have this turn
where you go
i don't even know if you remember this
you go hey hi ho you say like three
different things as you're working out
your it's
like masterful but i always wonder about
that moment like how do you make that
what would you say to people who who are
curious about that moment a moment like
that how do you how would you get
surprised or how do you wake up on
camera
yeah it's weird i don't know i mean it's
like
it's this this strange ability to be
totally invested in the moment
but at the same time
being able to watch it
to witness it yeah
in the same time
yes
being
aware of
you know you can make yourself
almost
emote
as you emote like holy [ __ ] i'm really
yeah yeah yeah it's it's moving that i'm
i'm being moved yeah you know it's just
kind of like it it's hard to explain
yeah almost like you're uh it's not out
of body because you're you're connected
to your body but it's totally connected
yeah yeah but you have an awareness i
uh i also love i want to talk about
riding cars with boys which i think is
um
one of my favorite performances to this
day but it's the [ __ ] you have to do in
that is so um it's a lot it's intense
and yeah it was
it was that was yeah it was a hard job i
bet uh did you study addiction did you
what did how did you pref how do you
prepare for something like that you
obviously lost weight and stuff but but
how do you get in the mind of an addict
like that because there was so much
desperation and it was heartbreaking to
us you do all this awful stuff to drew
and but it's heartbreaking it's so human
how do you do that yeah i don't know i
mean that character was really
but but there was a side to him that i
really felt sorry for i was you know
he was really vul he was just just a
simple
likable human being that was going
through horrible [ __ ] and that's yeah
and that's i think the hook that i was
like oh i can i can make this i think i
can make this guy really likable yeah
and that'll really help it yes yeah you
know because it gives her more power and
you know he's not just some
washed up idiot right it's
understandable why she would have
connected to him in the first place he
has so he really i really focused on
that right and i don't know i just kind
of and and also i was young and dumb man
how did that help it's just great
because you don't overthink things yeah
yeah i think that's why i live out here
i just don't overthink things i still go
into a situation like a set and here i
am a veteran like i i was talking to my
my kids the other day i was like i don't
think of myself as in my 50s i think
myself
24 yeah whatever yeah yeah isn't that
funny it's weird for me to think of
myself as like a veteran on set or
whatever
i think it's odd when somebody comes up
and goes
you know dude you know grew up watching
like yeah yeah okay we're gonna we're
partners now like okay yeah yeah i know
i know the hierarchy of it it's strange
so i like keeping that naidate
simmering so you so you do the play you
you do the program for two years and
then what was the first you start doing
touring companies you you talked about
tommy tune and what's the next step
what's the next big uh hurdle that that
that you take um is it especially in the
movie world is it is it suburbia is it
um
i think it's like well the first movie
was reality bites and i was really
excited about that and i was so nervous
and i you know i learned a lot and ethan
and i were good friends from before that
we had done theater together
so i was i was like dude what am i doing
like you know and he was great and and
made me feel good but then i you know
you come home and you're like i am more
poor than i was when i left my house
to go shoot a movie
[Laughter]
yeah i think it was like that thing you
do
yeah really kind of you know propelled
us all kind of
yeah i remember that being highly
publicized it was there was a lot of
magazine stuff about that and around
that time i was getting like
curious about it was like it was a dream
that i was just starting to have about
like becoming a professional actor i
remember seeing
to the point where i like fetishized i'd
get those magazines and i'd see remember
like you were in a lot of those things
like the next thing the next comedy guy
and and i think it's where i first
learned about you and and um
then i did a play with rockwell and and
i started watching all of his movies and
i discovered safe men and a lot of your
other and suburban all those but but was
it simply a matter was did that stuff
scare you was that like uh yeah yeah i
bet i bet yeah yeah that stuff is weird
i mean i mean i'm always
afraid i'm not saying the right stuff or
no i know i know i don't know even you
know
you know
now promoting the movie yeah i bet i bet
i bet you know well here i i said like
yeah i was really you're shooting that
movie was miserable oh yeah i know but
it was you know
i know but it was great i know i know
well that's why that's why i was so
grateful to work
holy crap yeah i know me too i know well
that's why i would have done anything
man but that's another rough sound bite
i would have told you anything
yeah don't put it yeah no no no no no no
that's why i like these things because
there's context for them and uh i want
to go back for a second to after that
thing you do was it
did did scripts change i mean did
you just have more access to
yeah yeah yeah it was weird but but
in hindsight one of my faults
is that i didn't and still don't realize
when i'm in a position that's a bigger
where it might propel me or i or
or i i should make a different decision
or you know and i remember being in
places where i was you know getting
letters from people and like
and and
and accolades and i but i didn't i
didn't realize the the moment i was in
yeah the potential i don't think if
anything would have changed because
my life is my life and i like living it
the way i live but
but it i don't know if that makes any
sense it's like now i go like oh i was
in that position where i could have i
could have become a player maybe and and
worked differently you know you're one
of those guys where a lot of people are
like oh yeah i know him he's always
great he's uh but and i know and sam was
in that position and and um
and but like i i've noticed a change in
how people talk about you just in the
last couple of months because of white
lotus and i'm sure
your agents and the people the powers
that be in your life have also
felt that and like you said had you made
certain choices had you taken certain
paths in the past you had so many of
those
white lotus moments where you could have
capitalized and been whatever maybe but
but we really do honestly react to to if
something's good or not not if you're
just in it you know you still have to
have that oh this is a great show and
there's no formula for that what is the
hardest part about doing this kind of
stuff i don't mean this podcast in
particular because i to me it feels like
this is great because we're pals but
yeah
but this stuff i mean usually i like
doing press
you know
you do because it's just odd and
interesting it's different and i get to
talk to different people yeah on a farm
yeah you know that's why i like going to
work man i like totally part of the
circus man yes yeah oh it's the set and
going into the hair makeup trailer and
immediately
you know joking and uh we're gonna hang
out you know i love that i love that
camaraderie the whole thing yeah and so
a junket
and a live junk that's really fun i
think
yeah
i do i like it too it's a
it's a chance to perform i mean it's an
element of performance um
and i it's so funny steve that i think
that's where i got that i often say that
like where you may have even said this
like we we're current i think i think
you said it we're carnies you know we go
where the hermit was tim busfield
whatever it's we're kind of we go where
the tents are i always love that you
know we do we we just go where the tents
are just attracted to it you know it's
like there's a light coming out of a
then people making noise and we just
like hey what's going on in there i mean
yeah i remember you know for most of
history we were we were what we should
be which is just kind of ridiculous yes
i know we weren't invited to the parties
you know oh we were in the fall of rome
i mean once you know entertainers got
paid more than their senators that went
downhill
that's true it is ridiculous what we do
and people will go like hey what are you
doing next i mean if you can't i mean
can you talk about it
is it cool if we talk about it you're
like yeah it's a stupid story and i'm
putting on costume and makeup and
they're recording it
yeah i know
why is this i know but yet hollywood
will even perpetuate that kind of like
you know
it's like it's so sacred okay
i had this is true
big movie big movie
steve you were offered a part
great
can i read the script
no
okay
correct can i read the scenes in the
script
no you can't read the script
but if and if we give you the scenes
that you're in we don't think you're
going to want to do it
because the script is amazing and you
and i was like
this is crazy that's crazy what do you
do what do you do
i didn't do it uh what [ __ ] i'm so
curious what it is now but it's it's one
of those it's probably a big like
special effects thing yeah i was just
like well i i can't wow i gotta have
some kind of connection to it it's not
just to be in it you're right
you know i gotta
all right you know i want to go and kill
it yeah
because it's like that's it's the doing
of it i mean we're similar i think in
that regard is that it you know to get
back to that would you rather it's like
would you rather just be famous for
doing other or like get to be be
creative but to me the joy is in the
doing it's in the in the process of it
totally man that's why we do stupid
little movies right you know i did a
movie called cowboys no one saw that
movie oh you can't wait to do this one
of my
best friends i've ever read and i was
like come on guys when are we gonna do
this two and a half years wait and then
we get there
and it cost me to do it
wow yeah
first
definitely
but it was it was totally worth it just
because i i got to be in those moments
yes yes you relish those moments i mean
like
yeah and you know when you read them the
special ones like oh man this day is
going to be crazy i can't wait to do
this day yes i know i know i know
what what was i know
my wife would even go like today's the
day i'm like yeah
yeah it's the scene with it you see this
daughter yeah yeah when you're just like
you know you're stella man i know i know
like
and you and ah yeah it's like getting
ready for the championship game man yeah
oh i feel that even like exponentially
now after the pandemic you know i got to
do a job in bulgaria that was this this
movie that was
similar there were days where i
the reason you you really not the reason
i did the movie but the reason i really
like looked forward to certain uh
certain scenes you know there were ones
that i was like relishing that was like
and i know i know that morning you wake
up excited there's a it is it's it's
even exponential now um
the the excitement to to dig into
something like that
and you know you're gonna you're gonna
you know you're going to do well yeah
yeah throwing the ball
knee the ball man you got it yeah yeah
what were there times where you were you
had those scenes but they were with
people that you were maybe so
intimidated by or you had to like really
muster some extra courage wha what what
comes to mind
um
all of it i always get nervous around
people yeah
actors
whether they're
famous or not yeah yeah
yeah i kind of i think that's why i over
prepare just out of complete fear you
know you learn the lines like ins you
strike me i mean you were like that on
strange wilderness you even a silly
movie like that you were always
your lines were always there is that
just a theater background too you think
i think so but i was enamored with i
also had the pressure of that movie
because you guys were brilliant at like
coming up with stuff in the moment and
and so i was like my job was to was to
steer the ship yeah yeah and i was like
i had an extra duty to keep it on the
tracks
because i was that guy it was that
character yeah so it was even more so i
was like oh my god i gotta kill this so
that those guys all that stuff
and then i'd laugh all the time
dude i was the worst well there's a
moment where uh jonah we're punt we
that's ridiculous movies called strange
wilderness but i love them i still love
them
it's so fun and i love when people come
up about it you know like dude strange i
always like those people you know i
immediately like people who are like
you know strange wilderness man
yeah yeah when they do that my immediate
i always go like oh you like pot
[Music]
yeah
oh you're high right now cool
yeah i like you uh but there's a scene
where it's in the movie i remember
thinking like oh i don't know if i've
ever and no one i don't think i think
it's hard to catch because you're in the
corner of the frame but you're um it's
when we're eating the fish that ate our
friend we're like we catch all the
piranha it's ridiculous that ate our
friend and i think it was one of those
moments that we all collectively were
like what did we do what is that it was
the most ludicrous but you have to
commit and we were all committed to it
and jonah was like
punching the fish i remember like you we
were like angry with the fish that we
were eating and you
you are laughing in the car
and i don't think they did a take
without it so it's in no no
there's definitely no when you shot you
just stood up and shot in the dark that
blew me i could not i never looked at
towards the camera
dang
dude there was a whole that whole
close-up of me this is film so it's like
you know the whole mag that's right it's
before digital reacting to all your
idiot stories yeah
you know it's like well i don't know why
kevin always made me laugh it's like see
this right here i got it you got a scarf
i was working
and i just
by the way that's an amazing impression
that's really funny uh i
yeah i know there was a moment that i
know it was a tough one to get through
uh i mean there's nothing better man
that is safe man there are so many
moments in that movie where you see us
turning toward the camera and just
passing camera
yeah
yeah i bet i bet uh especially when
you're rehearsing
um you're rehearsing for yeah yeah it
was like day one and we got in trouble
oh oh really who directed the hamburg
john hamburg yeah i just saw him on on
gower
it was crazy
yeah we had to face each other and i i
always remember it was like we didn't
sam
yeah the shot was behind us we go
spend [ __ ] oh yeah yeah yeah and then we
turn to each other
friendship
like
and we couldn't do it sam and i couldn't
do it we just turned to each other and
look into each other's eyes oh forget it
and it wasn't and john was pissed he was
like come on guys this is my first movie
you guys can't laugh for like an hour
and it's day one it's day one and we
were getting mad at each other like come
on man uh yeah i hate [ __ ]
do it again damn it stop it what how do
you do that what what if you're when
you're working with like i'm thinking
like rescue dawn with with i was just
going to say like yeah how do you do
that i mean
i christian and i by the way he's one of
the funniest guys i've ever worked with
uh no [ __ ] hands down top five funny no
[ __ ] swear to god
we had so much fun
oh wow
thank god because it was a hard gig
but there were moments where he and i
could not
keep our [ __ ] together there was one
scene where we were walking away
from verner and it was at night and
we're like
escaping and we're like you know walking
through the and
he kept yelling at us to turn around and
look back uh-huh
turn around turn around
yeah yeah he and christian and i were
laughing so hard oh you couldn't we
couldn't and he got more mad at us
because we didn't turn around oh we're
just so
you do it
that's amazing and then there was
another scene where we're in the and
it's verner herzog yelling so it's
probably like extra funny because he's
like turn around you know turn around
yeah
yes yes oh my god there was another
scene where we're in the camp we're in
our little hut which is for context it's
based on the documentary little dieter
learns to fly and uh so it's about you
guys have been shot down over vietnam
and i'm not telling you that true story
yeah yeah incredible story
yeah it's about a
prison escape
yeah amazing story and um you you got to
play a marine and uh you are air force
guy air force yeah and and but i
remember you telling me stories these
stories like
facts i think you had either just done
it yeah i think you had just done it
when we did it
yeah yeah yeah and so you you were i i
loved these stories but but sorry
continue just for context for people and
it was directed by verner herzog and
it's yeah it was it was just brilliant
it was just a joy to be on and i was we
were so excited but it was a little
movie you know in the middle of nowhere
um but we had the scene at night and it
was a scene where christian was
explaining all the guards and who they
were
and he was and we were sitting around
and he would be like okay
there's there's this one character you
know and it was i forget what i think
the character was little hitler
i'm not sure yeah it doesn't matter he's
like
he's up he's up in them
there was a watchtower he sets up on the
watchtower at night
he plays his flute all night
and the idea of playing his flute
all night and we
was it in the script
yeah oh man and we were like and werner
did not know why we were laughing he was
like you can't say that he plays flues
right
right but he did it's a true story so
you have to say it yeah and he he didn't
get it we had to
tell him the context
like he's up there
that's no you know what why is it funny
to you
wha what was he you told me some other
stories about how he wouldn't he may
like have you go because it was as you
shot it in as real away as possible i
remember that i remember like he wanted
you to and christian
probably didn't shy away from any of
that method stuff we're like no he's
you're right yeah yeah and really like
daring and and committed and like but
but you were do putting yourself in
similar positions you were you were
the people playing the guards i remember
you saying were quite
aggressive and you know they were
committed and and you were eating
grubs and stuff
what what was that like
it was great
yeah i mean it was really yeah the the
moment with the villagers it wasn't the
guards
that's a climax of the movie where
they're they're gonna attack me
and it was people that live in this
valley in the middle of nowhere they had
these machetes and they were above me
and i'm like and i was like whoa whoa
whoa whoa
explain to them that this is pretend
you know
in the interpret and they thought it was
crazy i was like no i need you to
explain to these people that this is a
[ __ ] movie
this guy this guy hasn't see he doesn't
have a mirror
yeah okay
[Music]
because werner also is like so he comes
from the documentary world so he was
probably like
i want he wanted it to be he had you
guys going i remember like weren't you
shooting in uh lao was it laos for
cambodia
we were in thailand it was thailand okay
i so then am i making this up that there
were he was sending you off into areas
that had potentially been like land
mined at one point
oh well we were up near
which was burma like really close
yeah yeah
it wasn't
i there's not as many mines but it it
was just kind of like a pretty hot area
for a long time but
snakes and stuff and like but it was
unclear it was like oh dude
we did a day where he was like the crew
is traveling to the next location and we
want to we're just going to drive all
day it's going to take us all day we're
just going to film on the way
and we just went with the camera no
sound and
we just pull over and he and i would be
in the ditch
like me and
had these
ak-47s we're like walking with our guns
barefoot and barefoot yeah we're just
next to the road and we hear this truck
coming around the corner and christian
and i have these guns
and it's a truck
with open back loaded with soldiers oh
my god and christian and i just go like
we
our initial
both of us had the same
instinct in the moment dropped the guns
we just dropped him immediately and
we're like hi
we're just hey
hey steve's doing chess
turn into tommy tune
yeah
we were the most unthreatening things
yeah ever yeah yeah yeah it's wild i
love that christian bale is so playful
and like
oh it was great
because i imagine i mean he's such a
[ __ ] great actor oh yeah but he was
he was just a delight man
like just so fun life could be a dream
hey life is short listeners i want you
to imagine that you're on a warship in
the final days of world war ii you're
excited to go back home looks like the
war is ending you've just delivered the
necessary parts for the atom bomb but
then disaster strikes your ship is
struck by enemy torpedoes and within
minutes you're floating in the ocean
fighting for survival from wondering
against the odds is an immersive podcast
that puts you in the shoes of resilient
people surviving harrowing ordeals in
their new season you'll hear about the
infamous sinking of uss indianapolis and
the survivors fight to stay alive it's a
fascinating story you probably know the
story of the uss indianapolis from the
famous scene in jaws that robert shaw
recounts
it is harrowing to say the least sailors
who survived the attack were stranded in
the open ocean for
uh five days i believe they endured
brutal weather
rough seas dehydration salt water
poisoning hallucinations and it was one
of the deadliest shark attacks in
history
against the odds has the harrowing true
story of how the brave men of the
indianapolis survived the worst disaster
at sea in u.s naval history listened to
against the odds on apple podcasts
amazon music or you can listen a week
early and add free by joining wonder
plus in the wondery app hey life is
short listeners business wars is a
podcast from wondering that brings you
the full stories behind some of the
biggest business battles in history in
their new season you'll hear about the
fight between espn vs fox sports to
dominate the sports television industry
espn is the american cable network that
plays the trail for around the clock
sports coverage athletes even change the
way they play just to get on
sportscenter's nightly highlight reels
but right around the corner rupert
murdoch's fox sports channel started
gaining on espn in the us the sports tv
business is worth more than 12 billion
dollars the question is who will come
out on top fox sports or espn listen to
business wars espn versus fox sports on
apple podcast amazon music or you can
listen one week early and add free by
joining wondering plus in the wondery
app
hello hello again
[Music]
doing something like that would have
been
without
the ability to let off some steam like
that it would have been so grueling i
mean like you go from that to strange
strange wilderness was like pure fun and
we're like doing these like
you know that was the next gig oh my god
you probably needed to do something
i read that script i probably told you
this i was in i was in a hotel in in
hanoi
oh [ __ ] they were like hey they want
they gotta know today
oh my god i was like i'll read it right
now i read it in my underwear in a hotel
in hanoi and laughed so hard
and i was like i don't know if it's
funny because i'm here yeah
yeah what i just did
yeah yeah i just ate insects and
walked in a jungle
you
god i'm so lucky man i just did this
hardcore drama and now i'm doing the
most insane comedy ever probably a good
way to like cleanse um
cleanse some of that stuff off
how did you you also lost a ridiculous
amount of weight uh and then and then
you lost about two pounds for strange
wilderness how did you lose all the
other
how did you lose uh
although wait how much did you lose for
rescue dawn i lost 40.
jesus christ did you did you and
christian do that together was that
something that he uh cause he had no we
talked about it but it was just like
dude i'm just gonna run and eat broccoli
and salmon that's what you you're
it was all diet it's all diet you must
have been farting a lot
yeah
what um
that's all that's what you did it was
just
no sugar yeah i was like
my wife just she hated it
wow i had one cheat day
uh-huh what was what'd you do on your
cheat day well at first i'd eat like
pizza
and then my stomach wouldn't be able to
take it oh i bet then i was like
you know i'd go like i'd have crackers
[Music]
i'm serious it's like my sister was so
cleansed like if i ate so pure
yeah if you did we got in a fight
because she was like dude let's get a
pizza and i was like i don't want to eat
a pizza it's your cheat day i was like
look you just want me to get a pizza
because you want some pizza and you want
to feel good about eating pizza right
right did you get i'm gonna get it and i
was like fine get it she's like you're
like a bulimic high school chick i'm
like yo [ __ ] you you know it was like
back and forth like you just want and
then we got the pizza
and and i was like you're gonna eat it
and she's like no
i'm not going anymore and so i went in
the kitchen and i looked at it
and i ate the entire thing oh [ __ ] like
she came in i left her like two pieces
and then she came in and was like oh my
god
can we start laughing
like i thought you didn't yeah and then
and then it was
when we fight it's over in like an hour
and a half oh really is there it because
you you must be good at communicating it
ends in laughter it ends in like what
are we doing this is ridiculous yeah we
live on a farm you know just like yeah
i'm good you're good okay cool do you
stay in touch with verner no
no i got i should i should actually i
should call him he has one of my
favorite quotes i think about a lot when
i when i look at animals because i have
a lot of deer in the yard
and and you know sometimes you know
better than anyone with the goats and
the horses when an animal like that just
locks sighs
with you when they just when they're
staring at you um i think about verner's
quote from grizzly man where he says
uh you know he's talking about timothy
treadwell and how he tread well when he
looked at the bear he saw friendship and
all these things and
overwhelming indifference
yeah indifference
but it's it's over the
the the footage of timothy treadwell
who's a fascinating guy who you should
if they ever make that narrative you you
should play that part but that would
do that
great wouldn't that be great
because he's such a character and yeah
um but they show him
kind of
teasing the bear a little bit like being
playfully teasing the bear
and in the subtitle he's like oh mr mr
grumpy woke up on the wrong side of the
bed you know like and the bear is kind
of lumbering in the background don't do
that don't you do that yeah yeah yeah
admonishing the bear bad
yeah and then the subtitles like this is
probably the bear that killed him
two days later yeah right i want to talk
for a second about war for the planet of
the apes oh yeah
how
you must
you're incredible in it but you must
have had to train
it must have been a lot of physic i
would imagine physical training for that
yeah that was that that was where i was
like i'm so thankful for my training i
remember sitting down with terry who who
played rocket and he was kind of the
coach of all the apes and it was my
first experience like i came into it
late i didn't go to ape camp so i had to
kind of do my own thing and i sat down
with terry notary and in his trailer and
he was it was lunch and he came in he
was like hey man like great dude just
like you totally trust him immediately
you know he's like let's just sit in
chairs man
okay
he was just sitting in front of me he
was like i just breathe man just breathe
it's just like
see how your shoulders going down
no
and in that moment i was like
oh [ __ ]
this is going to be a lot more involved
than i thought that's funny yeah and it
was like working from the inside out oh
wow not about like here's how you walk
like an a appears that yeah it was just
like it was all about like how how they
hold themselves and how there's always
strength
and analyzing like and it was just like
we look like you know when we're looking
at something you know we'll we'll we'll
look over at the thing when an ape looks
over it's like their whole and so i was
fascinated i was watching video after
video of these like chimps in in in a
zoo because a guy escaped from a zoo and
i was like
i was fascinated with videos of apes
chimps doing nothing oh interesting yeah
there's just the way they hold
themselves yeah they're always kind of
alert in there and
so it was a and i couldn't do this out
in public i couldn't go to a park and
use my my
arm extenders and practice i had to do
it my tiny apartment in vancouver was
all windows oh they didn't want any
leaked footage right they didn't want
you know to see the process oh wow wow
which i understood but if you had
binoculars and were watching my
apartment
is the dude over there doing some lucky
peep and tom did you have to study the
way they sounded the way they their
mouths i mean you did everything you had
to do there's effective sound yeah
which is the hard part um
you know they can make you look like an
a but everything else is up to you yeah
yeah yeah you know
like movement and
your voice and and all that
and i imagine that's got to be something
if you're not totally committed it's got
to be easy to laugh during that kind of
stuff dude i i've never been more
frightened in my life than stepping onto
the set of day one and we were shooting
my
where i live which was that chalet yeah
yeah and it was and i walked in and
there was this brilliant set that
probably took a month to build and here
i am with like amazing actors that have
done this
they're on their third movie right
that's right and i'm like i was so
petrified i i i was like i have to kill
it today
yes it's i have to do it
and that's what people don't understand
about movies you you have to do it the
first second
yeah
yeah you don't know like
in a week it's daunting and that's why
you know my daughter wants to do this
i'm like
you know go train now have people tell
you that you suck that you're being lazy
because eventually you're not going to
get that luxury you're going to go to
set and no one's going to tell you
anything you're going to be true have
you noticed a change since white lotus
it's so good everyone it's one of those
shows that like people talk about um and
it must have been it's just purely fun
to make you talk about the pandemic and
like you're in hawaii and
jennifer coolidge that cast what
do have people been spotted saying
things about that to you like in
kentucky or wherever you are
um yeah it's weird because i'll do press
or i'll i'll talk to people in the
business and it's a big deal it's a
water cooler yeah yeah i've never been
on one so that's interesting and like
wow a lot of people but when i was here
and it was out
no one's it doesn't yes i bet of course
because you live on a farm it's like
right hey man that white lady i heard
you get you had your dick and balls on a
show what the hell is that
like well it's not my dick and balls oh
it's not that's oh there goes my next
question
all right
hey you got a fence down back there i
know i know and then it just you know
yeah
it's true it's impossible to escape like
real life it's like what you said
earlier it's it it
illuminates the the idea that we're
[ __ ] jesters who are just like
reading lines that
we're just putting on clothes it's crazy
i i have a lightning round um which i
know we're running out of time um uh i'm
so curious about some of this stuff and
i'll you'll probably make fun of me for
the first question but here we go
what is your most commonly used pizza
okay your most commonly used emoji is
pizza okay oh man no it's you know what
it is it's a unicorn
oh yeah you you
yes
i like the unicorn it just
means nothing yeah you used one on me
the other day um
if you could be a professional athlete
what sport would you play football
lacrosse lacrosse okay i've never played
it but my son killed at it yeah and i
was like man if i had this game when i
was younger oh yeah yeah it would have
been great it wasn't big in minnesota i
bet it wasn't big anywhere well unless
you went to some private school in
maryland yeah yeah uh it was big where i
grew up in connecticut it was kind of
like a shishi oh it was huge yeah but
not anywhere else yeah now it's huge
everywhere and you didn't play hockey
huh no i had friends that played hockey
man i would i would screw around but i
never i never joined the team are you
what position did you play in football
corner yeah and i returned puns and
kicks uh was that scary were you afraid
to i mean if they're again i always seem
like a really scary position if they're
getting too close i was petrified yeah i
was petrified yeah yeah punts not kicks
pawns i was petrified and i would fumble
if that's a hang time dude i would i
would fumble if i made a fair catch
oh really so i never no that's this tree
yeah and so my brand i was like well i'm
never gonna make a fair catch oh jesus
i bet i would make fair catches every
time right time to and and
that's really funny i couldn't
coordinate my arms like the wave rain oh
yeah and bring i was like do they see me
you know i want to make sure you know i
was like i just fumbled it it just hit
me in the chest
sorry sorry sorry sorry
um if you could have one snack food for
the rest of your life what would it be
like beef cherokee okay did you say my
beef turkey
oh oh i heard you say my beef jerky no
probably something like that yeah do you
make any snack food yes enough just like
you watching a movie you want a pot you
get stoned and you want to like oh
oh like cheez-its oh geez it's okay what
is a movie that you really were like
excited when you had kids you were like
i can't wait to introduce them to this
to my kids yeah yeah
what yeah like to freak like a movie
like that that was important to you that
was special to you growing up that you
were like oh man there's a bunch yeah
and my kids i i told my kids like you
you when you leave here i don't care
what you do if you guys are
you know working for toyota i don't care
but you're not going to go to the to the
christmas party at toyota and and not
get references
you're gonna this is
my son actually asked me when he was
like 12 i was like can you go to school
learn how to do this i go yeah you're at
it right now dude keep watching the
movies i would show them every night oh
yeah and it was like
you're like
a god that the story of telling god when
you're just like okay sit down sit down
what's the movie
yeah
and you put it in and you go
enjoy
jaws yeah
yeah and you're somehow and they have no
clue oh isn't that that must be great
and you're responsible
and you're like
yeah and then they're like do you have
more stories
thank
story
and you're like yeah we're going to
watch and then it and then it goes into
other things you know it's like so just
close encounters and then and then you
show them something because they're so
advanced beyond their years in film
they're watching like dr zhivago oh my
god that's funny yeah well everything
and then i'd be like hey here's a great
one deliverance and then you forget
you're like
i'm not okay
okay
okay like i'm not going camping or
playing the banjo everywhere and then
you got to explain the whole thing like
he's like okay so he's being raped rape
is you know he's just like oh god man
forgot about this right or american
werewolf in london you know there's an
entire scene at a porno place oh yeah
yeah
just hear it and they're like what are
they watching you're like all right
jesus
yeah you have to explain life or i mean
there are even elements of that in
i was thinking about like never ending
story the other day where you know to
show that to a kid i remember watching
that as a kid or like dark crystals real
there's some really like dark elements
but never ending story there's a thing
approaching called the nothing
and like that's
like i remember that i think that was
one of the first times i felt like true
existential dread you know that the idea
that like there could be nothing
nothingness nothing um that's a kids
movie that's a [ __ ] uh advanced
concept i know now and now yeah you know
but it's like well that i found that or
like the exorcist yes
oh juiced and you forget about the one
thing she says that she's doing the
thing and you're like oh
right right hey do you guys want some
more popcorn she's talking right right
that's right
[Music]
you know and you're like
yeah what is your go-to karaoke song
safety dance oh great yeah
yeah safety dance um that was our that
was my prom song for some reason i think
kids put it in as like a joke men
without hats uh who was your first
celebrity crush uh probably when i was a
kid it was like melissa gilbert probably
oh yeah little house little house yeah
uh some prairie okay great
if you had to get a tattoo what would
you get and where it would be up here
just so i wouldn't have to cover it up
on makeup chairs oh yeah you like sam's
tattoo yeah and then it would just be it
would just be the word tattoo
that's great
that's great but misspelled me yeah
tattoo
that'd be good to get on your tat that
on your toe only a tattoo i'd get that a
tatte tattoo
that's uh who what is your favorite
fruit mango
oh yeah we get that a lot
it's tough to beat um who what's your
favorite uh who's your favorite muppet
animal yeah that makes sense um
what is your go-to pizza topping we
talked about pizza earlier
canadian bacon oh okay you prefer dogs
or cats
i get a bunch of cats let's just run
around oh i bet yeah farrell chaos you
have like bobcats hey check this out
dude oh
what's my nose whoa whoa whoa no you see
my nose no oh yes you've got a little
cut on your nose a little thing yeah i
got bit by a dog in in california up in
wine country oh no kid first of all wait
a minute yeah it was like a little it
was like a little sheep dog and it was
at these people's house
and he's a great winemaker and i was
outside screwing with the dogs going
and i was like oh [ __ ] i didn't tell him
because i was like i kind of was [ __ ]
with the dog what were you doing it was
like strange wilderness there's a scene
like that where you were blowing in a
dog's face
that's why i was laughing so hard i was
like oh you see
see this star
and i was a kid
[Music]
hit me right here i couldn't do it i
couldn't stop what was um
and you can't get mad you're like it's
kind of my fault sonoma county but um
so uh would you prefer the beatles of
the rolling stones stone oh okay yeah
you said that so matter-of-factly uh
have you see have you seen them play the
stones yeah oh wow
amazing you ever go to so i heard that
news shows me uh yeah so did i that he's
still doing it but he's that uh the
[ __ ] energy um this is great they
haven't missed a beat yeah okay well
well yeah
some things are different
these are different
uh
yes
well
what i we gotta go a year out of time
i'm out of time this is way too long but
i could do this for another
couple hours yeah i know it's the best
um i just gotta get it you gotta get a
haircut really quick um because this has
been plaguing me for a long time what do
you put on like you're eating a burger
you have a barbecue what do you put on
it
like what's your go-to topping for a
burger you just like
ketchup like avocado oh
like but i mush it up and i knew a
picture oh interesting i don't like the
piece of avocado that pops out yes it
does yeah that's a good point it's like
and then it's like i want to just eat it
yeah i don't want to have to like
squeeze it back in
like it's a it's an app yeah like a game
like how do you eat the burger yeah like
it's a
without
doing yeah well i i'm so glad we ended
on such a mundane
no
yeah dude but i i gotta i gotta um
oh um i got it i wanted to ask this hot
dogs
oh [ __ ] um you call me back you call me
yeah yeah
yeah i hey hey
do you like sesame seeds on your bun
i love you man i [ __ ] miss you i love
you too man this is the best
[Music]
so that just happened
yeah he's like he's kind of um
yeah there's a stonery quality to his
quality like a little bit of a hey man
yeah he's he reminds me of sam yes they
have a similar
dna it's a similar
uh youthful enthusiasm yeah that's true
still have you know and they're like
older guys now but they still and he
says that yeah and it's like a huge
compliment i think to
to say that about a person that they've
maintained a youthful energy yes i know
especially with
kids and a career and life on a farm i
mean he works a lot he's outside but i
think maybe that helps i think he's
he seems to to have retained his sense
of like play and yeah be you know
a work ethic that is like maybe fostered
like useful energy his enthusiasm for
doing what he does is
apparent like he he doesn't take
anything for granted and you like
genuinely seems to enjoy the work well
and that come comes across yeah i was
surprised in fact that he even wanted to
do strange wilderness i remember like
and that's one of the reasons
jonah and i really jumped at the chance
like we knew steve was doing it and the
script was like funny enough but it was
really like st it was really like the
chance to work with steven when i read
the script like he said it it's so dumb
but it's
funny but really dumb
i i remember being surprised that he
wanted to do that and a little nervous
to work with them because i you know you
just think they're going to be
super serious about their craft and like
and he was so playful and fun i mean it
was like the opposite of that he was
serious he was a good he was like
committed to what he was doing but we
laughed so much and
it's funny to hear him talk about the
movie he did right before that rescued
don that was very surprising that they
laughed on that christian bale was that
funny i know i think chris we've talked
about this but i think he gets a really
bad rap for being like super serious
because of that leaked audio maybe but
maybe but even before that i remember
thinking of him in a more
yeah because he's he has that reputation
being intense anyway um but he it was
cool to hear it makes me like him more
as an actor that he's like playful and
he like cracks up during takes yeah and
that's like the most fun thing to do
yeah you know oh man the outtakes of
from strange wilderness are so fun to
why and like you can i love watching
them because you really relive that time
that was
such a funny i think about that movie a
lot just because it was one of the most
fun
uh working experiences i've ever had we
just laughed so much and
then that night we went out
i wasn't there that night but i remember
you thought you were no i i but i
remember when you came back you were
like
it looked i think you came back and joe
you were with jonah and you you came
back and you both looked like you had
seen a ghost because like the vomit had
just happened
but it was like it was like it looked
like you had seen a ghost but in a funny
way
it wasn't like you didn't look scared
but you look like
this is like the funniest thing just
happened but you were like stunned by it
yeah it was stunning it was stunning
kevin hepburn is vomit
it was like oatmeal it looked like fake
it looked like a prop oatmeal such a fun
one of those epic nights but i remember
i have pictures of that night that are
every picture steve looks like um
deranged he looks like a like a feral
he's like his mouth is so big it was one
of those nights where like everyone just
needed for whatever reason like let let
out some steam let off some steam uh
yeah i don't know both an awesome steam
let out some steam i think it's let off
some stuff you know where we went we
went to renee's and and
the gas light the karaoke place oh my
god that's the place where jonah did um
sweet caroline and i think and and he's
saying uh
so when he's saying kiss from a rose
i've been and he kept pointing at these
like bro guys and kind of like
singing to them and no one knew what to
make of it and he started there were all
these like weird decorations in the
background he he started like
ripping them down and um it was really
funny performance before he was famous
now that would be oh no impossible for
him yes to do couldn't do that there'd
be phones out and
you know it'd be
it was a different era different
in a different world
um but god it was so fun to catch i i
love that he lives on a farm i know it's
funny you were you were like circling
the the topic of his acting prowess and
you're trying to
like understand what makes him so good
and like how he can
how he can be present he's like i don't
know i just feel like really invested
and like but but there's part of me that
i'm like i'm able to watch my own
performance in a way oh yeah so he's
trying to explain it but then
uh and then but then he was like you
know i i live on a farm and i don't
overthink things and he said that it was
like oh that's that's that seems like it
yes totally like he eventually he landed
on that which was like oh that that kind
of explains it in a lot of ways it's
funny like i i've taken classes and i
remember being in school and
reading about acting i mean there's all
people ask me like what can you do to
and i think that really sums it up i
alan rickman said a similar thing that i
love that there's a video of him talking
about acting in a similar way where it's
just like you got to get out of your own
way just be there be listen and be
present i mean it's
it's such basic stuff but it's
not easy to get to that point i think
somebody like steve is just there's
something so up pure and authentic well
i think like i was saying before i think
it also helps that he really loves it
and
and i think the life he's created for
himself is
it's there's something so enviable about
it he's got this family that he loves on
a farm with all these animals around
complete peace and quiet yeah with like
people he really likes kids who sound
like really impressive really impressive
yeah and then he gets to
fly off to a set and have this fun set
experience with these new people right
and the makeup trailer right and it's
probably just enough time goes by where
you realize how lucky you are to be in
that because actors are so taken care of
and it's such a like
privileged environment to get to like
you know you have snacks whenever you
want and then he returns to the
simplicity of this farm yeah it's really
impressive he figured it out smart good
uh tommy tune stories right oh my god
what did he do what was the f he just
went people yeah chris
you kind of you kind of take your two
your index finger and your thumb and
just like squish them it's like people
do that with um you know when you look
at someone
uh who's far away from you and like with
perspective and you just go
you kind of squish them with your
fingers it's such a funny visual like a
young times like eager and try to please
tommy tune who's like a big star
huge huge yeah and tall apparently which
i mean it's also like the physical
dynamics yeah tall legs
yeah i picture like the mr peanut you
know he was like
he was like a song and dance man with
like or like um jack skeleton
yes
yeah he like like put like pogo stick
like yeah
i love it
i love that um
this is really funny dynamic i steve's
also so good i wish i had seen more of
white lotus when i talked to him you
hadn't seen it right i hadn't seen it oh
i just seen it at all i could tell
because you were like you're in white
lotus and if you had seen it oh i would
have gone crazy 20 minutes i'm actually
glad i didn't see it yeah it would have
been gushy yeah and it would have just
been like chris farley-ish like
repeating like remember um in episode
three
but there's such great stuff i can't i'm
so excited for you to see it anyway um
i'm excited for everyone it's such a
great show mike white we should get mike
white on the show yeah and friend of the
show alexander dario yes alexandra and
uh hopefully future friend of the show
connie britton one of my she's one of my
favorite actors you want them all to be
friends at the show yes yes bring them
sweeney yes sydney bring the whole we
sat next to her at a
uh knicks game it was really fun
brag hello
not really were they courtside seats
well i didn't say that part that would
have been a brag uh no we were in the
nosebleeds that was back when the knicks
sucked and i know it was you were gonna
get this you were able to get those
celebrity tickets yeah they're good i
kevin bacon deserves everything so let's
not you're a preacher of the choir yeah
how good did he look courtside with with
kyra they looked i texted him all right
talk about a couple goals i felt so lame
but he he was really sweet he he never
makes me feel lame you know he's which
is what's that's what genuinely cool
people do yes i know they make lame
people not feel like i know and then he
texted me you're a lame person
well it was lame to be like i seen you
in the tv i
see you courtside but which i kind of
basically did but he um he sent a funny
thing back he took a picture with
latrell spreewall did i show you that no
yeah and he goes uh here's me because i
said you and cure looking whatever it
was like what did you say i don't want
to tell you i don't know what he's
saying you love opportunities to text
kevin well yeah sue me wouldn't i
wouldn't i know i mean i wouldn't sue
you he yeah i told you we hung out in
bulgaria so fun with kevin bacon yeah i
didn't tell you that i took him to a
great my favorite um panini place you
hung out with him i didn't tell you that
i don't think so yeah a couple of times
wow so he's a friend yes and um but he
sent back a funny he's like here's me
and kira and it was him in the trail
spray one he's like oops i mean what's
sprinkle
who by the way looks like a
distinguished but
uh older gentleman huh it's strange to
see people
athletes from that era from our like
youth um who whom we haven't seen in a
while by the way i saw willie upshaw
again at the gym today
and uh we've been justin i have been
seeing
legend yes baseball
around town lately when we were growing
up in fairfield connecticut shout out to
a whole town he um he was like the local
celebrity it was everybody knew him
before john mayer yes well john lived
there but he was uh not famous yet and
and so it's still cool to see
willie
yeah it was like i played baseball with
his son all right brag now who now who's
bragging um but anyway what are we
talking about uh cool moments oh kevin
but how great kevin is
and you know what else is great and i
bet they know each other steve's on
i bet they i bet they do they're such
cool and they've also been i mean talk
about six degrees of kevin oh yeah
there's been like so many great movies
and yeah and has worked with so many
great actors
that i'm sure they've crossed paths yeah
i'm sure you know what did i tell did we
talk about the safe man reaction that he
has
i tried to ask him i love that
how do you exactly answer that question
i i felt stupid afterwards because like
yeah you're right how do you answer that
like
i was present i just like what we said
like i was in the moment i was scared of
what was happening in the scene but i
came across scared but it's so realistic
it is so um
i was watching invasion of the body
snatchers again the other day and
veronica cartwright in that movie has
similar
fearful reactions that are so i'm so
impressed by that when people can like
this is a really hard thing to do to
pretend to be scared
when there are people around and it's
like i mean it's instead man i love that
moment i really nerded out on that great
movie yeah um let's read a letter let's
do it okay wow i almost said it myself
from mary vance subject oh cool this is
one of my favorite subjects
galapagos islands and poop stories
i mean i'm very polar ends of the
spectrum because if she knows you hi
justin and christian i love the podcast
and just listened to the h john benjamin
episode wow what a hilarious
conversation that went from talking
about rare globus birds to diarrhea in
your pants yeah i love that i love that
seamless transition i also love when
diarrhea is used as a verb yeah diarrhea
to go diarrhea all right diarrhea
i'm currently diarrhea yeah you don't
both have to love when diarrhea is used
as a verb um back to mary everyone loves
a relatable pooping your pants story and
h john has one of the best i've ever
heard it is one of them i've never heard
it better it's an epic poo story since
you seemed to enjoy the two topics i
thought i'd share with you my galapagos
poop story wow what a specific she has a
galapagos poop story in college i did a
study abroad program in ecuador during
the international student orientation
they warned us that since our american
stomachs were not used to ecuadorian
food we might experience a phenomenon
known as double spouting a vacuum
event oh my god evacuating from both
ends simultaneously we all laughed it
off and thought surely that won't happen
to me unfortunately just a few days
before a spring break trip to the
galapagos
i experienced this phenomenon firsthand
i'll spare you the gory details no the
glory details are what that's what you
need
but after an iv and an overnight stay in
the hospital i recovered and felt well
enough to travel to the galapagos
shortly after arriving i realized that
whatever medicine they gave me at the
hospital over corrected
and made me constipated for the next
several days i went on various
excursions around the islands and tried
to ignore my full belly
while snorkeling with tropical penguins
visiting the charles darwin research
station and spotting blue footed boobies
picture below that's so cool i
eventually became so uncomfortable that
i bravely ventured into a local pharmacy
with my basic spanish vocabulary
vocabulary to ask for something to help
combat my stomach problems embarrassed
and clearly a blond-haired foreigner i
looked at the ecuadorian pharmacist and
stammered out no puerto iral
which means i don't have to go to the
bathroom
if she didn't say that i said that
thanks duolingo oh not an ad not an ad
um back to mary she stared back at me
with a confused look on her face so i
tried again no puerto rica
roughly translates to i'm unable to make
poop a small smile of understanding
appeared across her face and she replied
with gusto ah si un laxativo i was
relieved in more ways than one i highly
recommend a visit to the galapagos
despite not feeling my best it was a
magical once in a lifetime experience
thanks for the laughs mary
uh yeah god i'm i've talked too much
about the galapagos but i really am
dying to go there it's one of my
favorite things to do is to watch just
i almost said programs i'm getting old
to watch nature programs about the
galapagos um i i need to go there it's
good story yeah i wish you had included
the corey i know but it's still a good
story yeah anyway we know would you
rather see ever would you rather me yeah
no not offhand nah
um would you let's see um
would you rather have maybe like a
constipated would you rather oh yeah
yeah would you rather be constipated or
double spouting
um no because he'd have to be
constipated how about this in general
would you rather be constipated
or
have
really loose yeah like an urge to have
diarrhea
often for a week
or for a week you can do one or the
other
and you can pick the week
well if you can pick the week then i
would pick a week where i don't have
much to do and take the diarrhea me too
yeah because you know at least you're
cleaning you're being cleansed
everything's coming out and and so i
would take that week to go on some sort
of like also let's face it
it's a nice feeling
and it's the opposite of the feeling of
that's true having it held in that is
true so in a way why wouldn't you pick
that as long as you had access to a
bathroom you would and you weren't
trying to impress a new lover oh man
yeah that would be a game changer yeah
both both would have to be constipated
yeah both would be tough i had to go i
was constipated recently at a um
uh dinner party and it was really tough
because i
you know since the pandemic i haven't
that's that's i haven't done that in a
while and uh gone to a dinner party and
so it's really bad timing um and you're
constantly aware of it it's like
that's just the worst
yes especially for you yeah i feel like
you have your issues some
bathroom issues supersede
those people's problems yes on your
problems uh anyway um any who any who
any poo uh thank you mary that's the
next letter great letter and it combines
your two favorite things arguably uh
yeah i mean throw monkeys in there then
you know
and monkeys you [ __ ] i don't actually
there aren't monkeys on the globe
because i don't think you could be wrong
about that but um i think if if there
were it'd be kind of disastrous because
they would eat a lot of the
eggs and stuff they would they would
probably wreak wreak havoc wreck havoc
wreak havoc
yeah yeah wreak havoc
if you guys would like to write reeking
if you guys would like to
write into the show our email address is
life is short at wondery.com and thank
you for listening thank you and thanks
to steve john for being on the show
my old pal i missed him it was also that
was one of the ones that was like really
selfishly it was just good to catch up
and here yeah that was a good ketchup
app yeah catch up ketchup pep uh and
thank you guys for catching up with the
show yeah and go you're all caught up
and go watch
white lotus oh man white lotus white
lotus
and all the great steve's on
performances yes do yourself a favor
yeah and do you mention strange
wilderness
strange children uh okay yeah so thank
you guys for listening
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it is co-hosted by you christian
law and also produces it but another
producer we should mention is megan v
monaco and there's even another katie v
allen and the senior producer on this
one and all of them michelle miesh
audio engineer sergio enriquez executive
producer marshall louis company name
wondering thank you
[Music]
maybe funny idea for a song now the
whole song is about how
someone's singing is like you know this
song right you know this song
and then it gets into like come on okay
and then remember this part then there's
like the chorus and here it comes and
it's like this and it's just
that it's
like shaming
around you for not knowing
like come on oh now
now you're gonna get it by the end
you're like yeah
see i just know you're seeing the chorus
really loud like i can't believe i have
to sing this but here it is
this is the song
you